es Costa Rica pero también Nicaragua
especialmente para los medios de
comunicación
185 periodistas nicaragüenses han salido
al exilio desde 2018 el caso más
paradigmático es el del diario La prensa
El más antiguo del país con 97 años de
existencia en julio de 2022 toda la
redacción se exilió en Costa Rica Fabián
Medina es su editor un periodista igual
a un narco periodismo y narcotráfico o
algo así un delito grave que se
considera grave
ejercer el periodismo en Nicaragua y se
y se percibe como tal
les confiscaron sus instalaciones y
allanaron sus casas es el caso del
fotorreportero Óscar Navarrete después
de cubrir la expulsión de Nicaragua de
las monjas misioneras de la Caridad se
me llevaron equipos de la prensa y
equipos míos personales entre ellos
computadoras tablet laptop cámara
fotográficas lentes y yo vine acá a este
país con un iPhone 7 y eso no me detuvo
de seguir haciendo periodismo gráfico la
prensa no ha sido el único medio
perseguido en Nicaragua 22 periodistas
han perdido la nacionalidad como Lucía
Pineda ubau que además llegó a estar
presa cerca de seis meses antes de salir
a Costa Rica su medio 100% noticias fue
confiscado también su casa hemos sido
encarcelado hemos sido robados nuestros
medios de comunicación nos han robado la
nacionalidad nos han despojado de
nuestros pasaportes
nos han perseguido incluso la
persecución contra la prensa se filtra
por las fronteras centroamericanas como
en El Salvador de nayib bukele El Faro
uno de los referentes en investigación
de América Latina ha decidido mover su
operación administrativa y legal también
a Costa Rica Sergio arauz es uno de sus
directivos también forma parte de la
asociación de periodistas del Salvador
estamos en un momento muy crítico
desde hace algunos años Creo yo que el
bucalismo ha montado un escenario
dispuesto para
restringir la labor de los periodistas y
de los medios Honduras y Guatemala
tampoco escapan de la persecución contra
la prensa convirtiendo a Centroamérica
en una zona roja para aquellos que se
atreven a fiscalizar al poder